Monday night at MetLife Stadium Jamal
Adams running across the formation and
giving a nice little pop to Baker
Mayfield drew a fly I'm sorry that is
not roughing the passer if you're
watching on TV you can see it if you're
listening on the radio trust me on this
he had one step there was no helmet to
helmet contact it was a shove to the
ground you're running full speed when
you hit the guy what are you supposed to
do stop so he got flagged and to make
matters worse Chris Sims
Jamal Adams was fine $21,000 for that I
don't think it should have been a
penalty at all and I wonder whether or
not they imposed the fine just to prop
up the fact that it was a bad call cuz I
really do think it's a bad call what do
you think I've said five times it was a
bad call do you think it was a bad I do
think it was a bad call I do and I'll
tell you what bothers me even more okay
it's enough that it's a bad call and he
got the penalty and okay I could deal
with the penalty I understand we're
protecting quarterbacks but why did we
have to add the insult to injury with
21,000 on top of it to me in a sport
where the guy's doing his job and it's
not egregiously bad like okay if it was
late alright
I mean it's not like it was like the
worst late hit we've ever seen in our
life let alone he didn't lower his head
or try to do anything that was dirty at
all in any way shape or form and I just
you know I'm kind of sick of that too
just like this constant like okay so
you're gonna hurt the team and now we're
gonna hurt the player and take money out
of his pocket for some of these things I
think it's just a little overboard in my
opinion and Baker Mayfield was out of
the pocket running toward the line of
scrimmage Thank You Adams could have hit
he could have hit him low he could have
taken his knees out if he wanted to and
and I just I don't get why that was a
penalty and here's Jamal Adams tweet
disputing the fun this league is a damn
joke he said I just got fined $21,000
for this hit I signed up to play
football not to hand touch but I don't
give a damn about these soft rules
protecting quarterbacks I'm gonna play
my brand of football every time I step
on the field s
Shh so well there's a word that's
blocked out there I wonder what that
word was now all bull all bull okay
that's what there we go
ah thank you for blocking that out and
because I probably would have said it
because it is it is the fine is the flag
is and III I mean the quarterback's and
I cannot ma'am I don't know maybe maybe
they're maybe they're sending a stronger
message Chris given what happened to
Drew Brees and Ben Roethlisberger right
they're gonna protect the quarterbacks
even more they're gonna be even more
likely to find players like Jamal Adams
because they don't want the quarterbacks
to be touched because they don't want
two starting quarterbacks going out
every week duty in well okay but I mean
nobody touched do you know nobody
touched you know and Ben Roethlisberger
I know it's just it's I know you're
right maybe there's gonna be more that's
what's just it's that's bullcrap and
then to take money has a buyers pockets
god forbid at some point Colin
Kaepernick would end up getting a job we
got to keep these quarterbacks healthy
because we don't want anyone to have no
option an alternative to signing my cap
it's not happening give it up okay but
then go ahead well my issue too
to just add to the conversation all
right is I mean you and you made it
already
if these quarterbacks you're gonna run
out the pocket and scramble and do this
stuff and hold the ball to the very last
second come on it's not fair what's
being asked all even further with this
Mike the plate Trevor Simeon got her
done by Miles Garrett wasn't a late hit
either very borderline I mean okay maybe
I understand them calling it but he runs
to the right he holds the ball he then
decides he wants to set back up and try
to launch a ball down the field and
miles Garrett I watched the game on film
yesterday he took half a step after the
guy threw the ball maybe one step and
hit him it's just we're bordering on
like ludicrous II of this protection and
the quarterback stuff I just don't it's
overboard it's not fair to these
defensive players and I do think
something needs to be done with plays
like that that are that borderline
alright and nothing dirty is done within
that play like come on
let's stop like taking money away from
guys for for playing football and a
sport where it's not perfect and your
your your they're making their money for
their aggressive acts in nature anyways
and they're not going overboard with
those type of hits there remember last
year there was that early emphasis on
the body weight rule and the flags being
thrown in the Clay Matthews play that
gave the Vikings another chance to to
force a tie at the end of regulation in
week 2 and yeah and the pushback right
there was the outcry and there was the
push back and the NFL adjusted and it
feels like this year instead of it it's
ramping up and I really do wonder at
some level whether there is a desire
whether it was spoken or unspoken the
idea that we have to almost put these
quarterbacks in bubble wrap and we're
gonna protect them even more than we
have because the league will implode if
too many starting quarterbacks get
injured I mean as of four weeks ago
starting quarterbacks due to be on the
field week one seven of them are now not
going to be on the field week three
starting with Andrew Luck's retirement
and culminating in what appears to be
Cam Newton not playing this weekend
seven out of 32 starting quarterbacks
gone not for the season you know some
will be back but but still they're there
they're not able to play and when you
start taking quarterbacks twenty-five
percent nearly of the league's
quarterbacks off the field that
diminishes the product and it may very
well be that this year the league is
going to call these closer and tighter
and tougher on defensive players because
this is part of the strategy of
protecting quarterb well is but it's
overboard and we got a lot of good
quarterbacks still left in football I
mean somehow the NFL survived the year
after Peyton Manning retired I don't
know how we did it but we did it I mean
it's amazing and did not anybody like
the Nick Foles story I thought that was
a great story but now we don't want it I
mean I don't know I'm just sick of it
you start encounter backs
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports